[Music]
mark it is so lovely to be here with you
today thanks for joining me yeah thanks
for having me of course so let's start
off tell me about exactly what goalt
does so gold bolt is a tech enabled
sustainably driven ENT to-end logistics
company which is a bit of a mouthful
which basically means that we take
product into our warehouses we move it
across our Network and we get it to
Shoppers who's your Target customer so
we we are increasingly working with
Enterprise customers so mostly Fortune
500 to intelligently distribute their
inventory manage their middle Mile and
their last mile delivery and how did you
get the idea for this tell me about the
founding story here yeah so this is an
interesting one where it's actually
nothing to do with what we do today so
we've kind of stumbled into what we are
now so so bear with me the business
started as a company called second
closet we would pick up store and return
people's stuff it was a valley storage
company we launched into the
international student Market where we
would store international student stuff
over the summer bring it back to them in
September and kind of rinse and repeat
and we launched that business by
basically breaking into dorm room
buildings and slipping business cards
under their dorm room doors and putting
flyers in front of urals and inside of
bathroom stalls I love it and so with
500 bucks we built a 20K a month
business in 2 weeks and we said okay
well we should probably quit the jobs
that we haven't started yet and and do
this fulltime that's really cool so now
how did you know parents you know
friends people in your life react when
you said you know right out of college
you're going to just start your own
company was there any any doubts or was
it hard my brother and I were on our own
since I was 17 so we were totally
financially independent we were just
living together and we had moved out so
it was basically do or die and I was in
the mindset of getting like a typical
corporate job and having like a stable
stable life so when I was recruited into
management consulting and had this you
know pretty amazing salary coming out of
University I was like okay well our life
is now set and we can kind of breathe a
sigh of relief so when I told my friends
that I was quitting the job that I
didn't start yet to do this and make
basically nothing and eat ramen noodles
all day there were some people looked at
me weird and others were like hey this
is totally what you should be doing and
I convinced my co-founder hindrik to to
start with me and quit his job which was
even better than mine and we are now
building this this incredible
business so talk to me about the scale
of your company can you tell me about
your your Revenue how many customers you
have anything like that yeah so so the
business is just over seven years old we
are over a thousand people strong and
Counting we do nine figures plus of
Revenue annually and and that's gred a
pretty pretty rapid clip and we're
really excited uh about what the future
holds for us I know a lot of under 30
community members tell me that they feel
a lot of impostor syndrome because
they're they're so young and they're
young Founders and it's hard to you know
speak up in a room of older more
experienced people do you ever feel like
that and how do you combat that if so I
I have not felt it yet and I think part
of the reason is as HRI and I built this
business we've always been very heads
down so we've never used anyone else's
yard stick to measure our success we've
never looked at competitors to see how
they're thinking about what we're doing
we've always been very driven to serve
our customer and so long as our customer
told us that we were doing a good job we
would feel like we're doing a good job
and that's all that really matters at
the end of the day your age you could be
90 you could be 12 it it doesn't really
matter just as long as you're driving
the right outcomes and so I think our
yard stick is what does our customer
tell us and what does the Shopper tell
us and if they're telling us that we're
doing a good job irrespective of our age
then we think that we have the right to
be doing what we're doing and one last
question for you you said before that
you were on kind of the precipice of of
do you take the the leap into
entrepreneurship or you know do you go
into the stable job what advice would
you have for for people who are kind of
in between both of those worlds right
now the younger you are the less risk
you have for others around you and I
think as we've grown the business you
know we have over a thousand people and
I now have to consider every single one
of them in the decisions that I make but
at the time it was really just myself
and a couple people so I I think the
Younger You are the more competitive
Advantage you innately have to make
financially daring decisions whereas
later on in life it's a lot harder
because there's more at stake so I think
the sooner you can get into
entrepreneurship I think that's why you
see so many brilliant young people today
do really crazy Innovative things is
because they're just crazy enough to try
and do it and there's there's not these
life encumbrances that they may hold
them back at the time we we didn't know
what the reward was but we were fully
prepared to see it
[Music]
through
yeah